let's get reaction from former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee along with former
senior counselor to president Trump
kellyanne Conway kellyanne your reaction
all this to me the biggest issue is they
La they were lying to the people of
Pennsylvania he's made a full recovery
he's doing great he has a little bit of
cognitive dysfunction but otherwise
everything's fine everything's obviously
not fine
Sean is not fine and may I remind
everybody John Federman already has a
big job he's the lieutenant governor of
Pennsylvania right now he's the number
two most powerful person representing 13
million pennsylvanians you ought to be
forced to resign and people should
actually question his ability to do his
current job let alone one in the Senate
so I think that's the situation here if
you put aside his obvious health
challenges the lack of transparency and
integrity and honesty and humility the
motivators for him and his wife by the
way so Craven to hold on to that power
to get the next political position she
threatened Dasha Burns a journalist she
said Dash Burns should suffer quote
consequences and ask people to go after
her and indeed they did meanwhile
everybody was under selling his obvious
Health deficits and there's something
else going on here
this guy was in a primary with three
other two or three other Democrats and
they lied then too if you're Conor lamb
tonight how do you feel this this guy
asked himself as a moderate from Western
Pennsylvania who could have taken on Oz
and another thing I see that I see the
Democrats right now because hokel was so
terrible last night against zeldon
Whitman was so terrible against tutor
Dixon obviously John Federman was the
worst against Oz they're now going to
tell us debates aren't even important
because they need to run Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris in debates next time so
watch for that everybody it's not just
that this wasn't a good format for John
fetterman that why are we even doing
debates they're not important yes they
are they are Central to democracy and
the last point I want to make here ever
since this race became about John
fetterman he's been losing but I want to
give mement Oz his due he was fantastic
last night he came with a full grasp of
the issues he has solutions for
Pennsylvania the very first thing Oz
said to fetterman was we need to get
back to civility in Washington and
fetterman was attacking oz so I know 92
percent of the coverage is about
fetterman look at mement Oz and know
that he and his wife Lisa are being
motivated through Public Service they
don't need the money they don't need the
fame they don't need the power they're
giving so much of that up to go and
serve in the United States Senate in
Pennsylvania that shows you the stark
contrast between the fettermans and the
houses well said kellyanne your take
Governor Huckabee
Sean let me just say I speak as a person
who spent the better part of 30 years
either as a candidate or somebody
holding office and something that people
need to understand it's one thing if you
have a disability and you're impaired
and you're trying to just make it but
you choose to step into the arena of
politics it is not something that is
thrust upon you you make that decision
you sign the papers to become a
candidate and when you get in the arena
it is a full contact sport played
Without pads when people ask me about
running for office I tell them the first
thing you've got to be prepared for if
you can't stand the side of your own
blood don't do this because it's brutal
there is a reason Sean I don't try to
get out on the field with the Dallas
Cowboys and try out for the team because
I'm not qualified and I couldn't hack
the physical endurance of an NFL game
what we're simply talking about and I
try to sometimes bring humor into my uh
conversations with you there's nothing
funny about this but politics is not a
game in which everybody gets a trophy
and the issues are not just his health
but the issues of the positions that he
took I heard some commentators try to
accuse Dr Oz of being a bully if
anything he was unbelievably kind and
gentle with fetterman on his physical
impairment but he cannot be gentle on
the issues because those are issues that
affect not just 13 million people in
Pennsylvania they affect 330 million
people in America and God help us if
he's the 51st vote on some of the issues
that we face in this country his
positions are the most radical of any
candidate I've ever seen Run for the U.S
Senate a great analysis from both of you
uh kellyanne thank you Governor thank
you as well hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else